hi i'm maria i'm a tasty producer today
i've been challenged to take a common
food and make it fancy let's see what we
are making fancy today
fruit loops as you can guess i've never
tried this before grounding up i eat a
lot of cocoa puffs i
am hoping it tastes like fruit i hope
different color has a different flavor
look like a pile of
poison
it doesn't taste like fruit
it's all same flavor i like the crunch
internet likes colorful dessert it can
be really pretty it's not too bad but
maybe if you're eating bunch it might be
a little bit too sweet so color is
actually cute and very festive so i
think we can make some fun dessert i'm
excited to make it fancy
right here's what i got butter heavy
cream eggs and milk from the pantry i
got cornstarch salt vanilla extract
sugar flour white chocolate product and
brandy okay let's get started
make it fancy
first step i'm going to use fruit loops
and i just realized fruit spell like
f-r-o-t not like fruit fruit
just like a meme if you know what i'm
talking about four cups of fruit roots
three cup of milk that's a big breakfast
i also don't know like why it's the
appropriate amount of cereal you have to
eat for breakfast sometimes like just
bowl of cereal doesn't look like enough
so i'm heating up medium high heat kind
of extract more flavor from fruit roots
as soon as little bubbles coming
from the milk that's ready just don't
boil the milk really do you recognize
the bird on the box
no
it's he famous he's famous so his full
name is
i used to have a bird that talks like
parakeet like little one he
came to my grandma's yard and she kept
it and i think it was barred from some
sort of station it says like next stop
is such and such
i know the little bird that talks
they're smart milk it's simmered i'm
going to pull over and gently push so
there's no dry spot just dip this about
one hour and we are moving on to next
step two cups of fruit roots so you kind
of want to make it like a pebble like
this sides so i'm going to just use like
big piece for later sugar part is going
to go through the mesh sieve if you
don't have a food processor you can just
put it in bag and crush them with
rolling pin or something right what do
you have a weapon be your choice
it's kind of pretty it's like fairy dust
and moving on to the next step okay so
we've been steeping through ribs for one
hour we are going to string it's kind of
jiggly
sounds like you are stepping into the
bottle
half cup of cereal milk half cup of
water and we're gonna save this later
i'm going to use one stick of butter and
cut it small sizes so it melts faster
and two teaspoons of sugar melt all the
ingredients the color is not as good as
i was hoping for but i think we have
some idea to fix everything is melted so
i'm adding one cup of flour medium heat
the dough is kind of shiny and it's kind
of foam into like one big blob take off
the heat and you want to wait this dough
cool to touch about five minutes so
dough is cool down our egg one by one i
think we will need four eggs but it
depends on the consistency mix it
you have to make sure all the egg is
absorbed second
if you have a stand mixer you can use
stand mixer with a paddle attachment
it's expensive machine so i just want to
show you how to do it by hand the dough
has to be a little bit runny
and gonna go for four eggs i think we
might need one more i'm cracking fish
egg but i think i'm gonna use just a
half first eggs come in different shape
so consistency is the indicator not the
amount of egg let's test it so you kind
of bring out the dough
i think it still need just a little bit
it's a good workout yeah like that
that's a good texture quarter cup of
crushed fruit ribs pretty look it became
gray to rainbow put this in a piping bag
and put the piping tip and twist
and
inside and bend so
when you put the dough it doesn't
overflow it's alive i'm going to pipe
the stone onto the baking sheet i spread
oil underneath of the parchment paper so
it sticks to the pan brush water into
the paper so it helps powder shoe to
puff up without drying up to make sure
each dough
has enough room because it's gonna rise
so when you're squeezing you don't want
to squeeze from here you kind of want to
squeeze your dominant hand on the top
and also you don't need to do like swirl
you just have to steady pipe we made a
pattern shoe at the culinary school also
this was maybe my first pastry i made
with my mom i love making karachi i like
the transformation i sometimes even
weigh in front of the oven so i can see
it's pops up and this is ready
really you're fast
oh i've seen faster whoever doing this
like at the professional level they are
so fast cool cute so you don't want this
point so you wet your finger with water
and kind of make it flat and this
moisture also helps this puffs up i like
this it's cute missing round it's cute
so i was a little bit worried because
when we steep
loops it was great but now because of
the egg and because of the crushed fruit
loop it looks very festive and cute it
looks almost like a funfetti cake so
this is the egg wash leftover i think we
don't have enough so i'm gonna add a
little bit water it kind of gives a
shine when you finish baking so we are
going to bake this at 400 fahrenheit for
20 minutes and then lower the heat to
350 fahrenheit bake for 10 to 15 minutes
until golden brown when you're baking
don't open the door if you open the door
it won't rise so i have reserved fruit
root infused milk heated up two egg
yolks
two tablespoons of sugar i'm gonna mix
it until pale this is a little bit
crucial part when you're making custard
you have to make sure the sugar is
absorbed into egg yolk two tablespoons
of cornstarch and one teaspoon of
vanilla so milk is start bubbling add
just a little bit so you're kind of
tempering put
gentle stream bring this back to a pot
turn on the heat and cook this until it
thickens you want to consistently mix
with rubber spatula because it will burn
if you don't do that or it's become like
cuddles pastry cream is done transfer to
a bowl not the prettiest color but we're
gonna fix it you want to make sure the
plastic is touching to the custard so it
doesn't form a skin chill this until
completely cool about 30 minutes
and
it's not pretty let's make it pretty one
tablespoon of randy just mix it separate
this into three
i usually avoid using food color but
this color is a little bit off-putting i
like the kind of color for fruit loops
so i'm adding a little bit of food color
we have pink we have glue and we have
purple what's your favorite color you
know it's difficult to pick your
favorite color whenever people ask me
that question i don't have the answer
but i tend to choose like a stone color
for my clothing and red for like
accessories set this aside i'm gonna
whip some cream i'm gonna start with one
and a half cup
i know there is one person on instagram
he made at least three or four things
from mega fancy we should give him a
prize
perfect
consistency so cream is whipped it's a
stiff peak add two custard mix
it's just one big scoop it's like
eyeball okay the fillings are ready and
i'm going to use this piping bag this is
a special kind of tool if you don't have
it you can just
make one color i want to make like
unicorn
effect so i got a special tool that
makes three color cream
one done
and two down three down
put them together
so i'm gonna set this aside and move on
to the next step all right
look how cute it is perfectly puffed up
i'm going to cut top part you can see
the froot loops inside pipe you're
unicorny
i'm very happy if it's not hollow enough
you can just push the inside part look
how pretty they are
i don't know i don't like eating
colorful food but i like making colorful
food deep white chocolate it's melted
put like a hat and put fruit loop i'm
topping with fruit loops because it kind
of gives nice poppy color and adding
more flavor and more texture
so cute i'm very happy it's the cutest
thing i've ever made on this show i'm
gonna put on the plate this looks great
and we are done
[Music]
they are unicorn fruit loop cream
puffs welcome back jasmine thank you
can you tell what i made fancy from can
i smell it yeah
froot loops yes
can you tell the difference between
fruity pebbles and fruit loops well
that's why i asked to smell it oh it's a
difference i can smell the difference
fruity pebbles smells a little more like
juicy and then froot loops smell a
little tangier but you have a good smell
yeah people like think i'm a dog oh wow
yeah my hunch is that you made cereal
cream puffs yes with
a
[Music]
a whipped filling and a donut icing top
of some sort
[Music]
this is delightful very fancy i love it
thank you some rainbow foods are so
saturated to the point where they taste
chemically sweet
this is light fluffy nice crunch with
this cereal
it's heavenly fruit loop everything but
not too overpowering yes
so jasmine did i make
i
did i make flute loop fancy yes you did
okay thank you
thank you
make it fancy
[Music]